if a youthful obsession with japanese
samurai cinema and an audiobook version
of musashi have taught me anything it's
that if you want to be a great sword
fighter having a connection to nature is
important
skill with a weapon isn't purely driven
by physical strength and technique but
also the acuity that comes from
observing trees
mountains and rivers something like that
while i can only really make guesses to
how inspirational the rural areas of
feudal japan would have been the scenic
island portrayed in ghosts of tsushima
an open-world 13th century samurai epic
is one that often stirs something inside
of me
beyond being a game centered around
flashy sword fights and the journey of
jinsakai to becoming a proto-ninja ghost
of tsushima invites you to lose yourself
deeply in its grasslands forests and
mountains
and though the tasks you're given often
aren't as brilliant as the color of the
leaves
there's certainly something wonderfully
humbling about just riding your horse
through this beautiful environment and
taking it all in
and what an immediately beautiful world
it is full of bold saturated colors
grandiose weather effects and an
overabundance of wind swept
leaves petals butterflies and other
small particles that make every location
feel alive
the island of tsushima is a painters
palette vibrant red and yellow forests
sit on top of inviting green hills by
day and blinding sunsets
soak everything in a deep orange at
night bright white moonlight glistens
off dark blue
lakes and waterfalls to illuminate
everything around you the game has an
option to turn everything black and
white in order to mimic the samurai
films of akira kurosawa but using it
forgoes sushima's own distinct visual
identity
at times it almost feels as if the art
direction is trying a little bit too
hard to draw attention to itself
and ghoster sushima certainly makes a
concerted effort to try and absorb you
into its radiant world even further with
its deliberate lack of navigational
information
there's no option for an on-screen
mini-map or a compass to see which way
you're going and objective markers are
barely there
instead the game features an in-world
device called guiding wind
in which the game's plethora of organic
particles will subtly fall towards the
location of whatever
objective you need to reach a swipe of
the dual shock's touch pad will
magically and visibly summon a strong
gust
that kicks up even more particles in an
almost comically self-indulgent way
which acts as a more obvious nudge in
the right direction and it's a great
system
without anything to draw your eyes away
from your character in the world the
guiding wind pushes you to pay more
attention to your surroundings to let
you more quickly internalize key
landmarks that help you get your
bearings more easily later on
or just to feast your eyes other inward
devices like plumes of smoke
flying songbirds foxes tory gates
talkative non-player characters and more
helps to guide you towards new
activities a lot of these activities
also work in service of making sure you
see sushima's good side
foxes will invite you to follow them
down charming paths to nearby inari
shrines
torii gates will lead you to simple but
daring looking platforming challenges
that reward you with spectacular vistas
haikus ask you to sit down and reflect
on your picturesque surroundings and
singing crickets will
unlock songs for jun's flute which let
you magically command the dramatic
weather at will
you get equipment early on that helps
you track down the game's myriad
collectibles
through the guiding wind and controller
vibration and some convenient touches
like a generous and very quick loading
fast travel system help make tsushima
be an incredibly pleasant place to move
through especially when you're armed
with the game's robust photo mode to
take screenshots with
while you do need to enter a menu-based
world map if you want to go somewhere
specific without a marker to constantly
signal your next objective's location
you definitely get a little less
obsessed with taking the most direct
route and you feel more naturally
inclined to just follow the winding
roads around mountains and along
riverbanks
guiding wind creates a flow that gives
you plenty of opportunities to drive
your own curious exploration as an open
world device
it also succeeds in masking the feeling
that you're simply being strung along by
objective markers even though that's
still
exactly what you're doing that feeling
still does come up unfortunately
when ghost distinction is quests
referred to as tales take all of the
reigns
tales fall back on rote open world quest
structures where you do things like
follow a quest giver to an objective
maybe have a chat on the way and veering
off the assigned path here isn't allowed
sometimes you'll be asked to survey or
examine an environment
activities which have the ability to
devolve into meticulous hunts for
interactable hotspots
some early tales have you chasing
mcguffin after mcguffin to the point of
being silly making you wonder if
anything is going to happen at all
anytime you're not engaged in combat a
lot of these quests
especially side quests can feel like a
drag the cut scenes that host
conversations between jin and other
characters
which give context to these tales
largely feel stilted which further
underscores the tedium that's not the
fault of the acting ghost of tsushima
has some passionate and strong sounding
japanese voice work
at least to my non-speaker ear though
there is a visible disconnect with
character lip syncing which keeps the
mocap performances of the english cast
who are notably all asian even though i
prefer the japanese voice audio the two
tracks do offer some differences in
regards to their overall tone the voice
work is largely let down by a noticeable
lack of bodily expression in the almost
motionless character models meaning
you're basically just watching a couple
of talking heads most of the time
now obviously that's not uncommon to see
in titles of this nature but it is a
significant low point in a game that
otherwise
hits so many stylistic highs the
cinematography which frames the
characters in pleasing ways within the
gorgeous scenery
instead does the heavy lifting to make
sure these regular moments are at least
somewhat pleasing to the eye
though wide shots do draw more attention
to the fact that the two conversing
bodies are standing perfectly still most
of the time
this means a lot of the games emotional
arcs and vibrant characters don't hit as
hard as they should
ghost of tsushima clearly aims to evoke
golden age samurai cinema in many ways
but it doesn't manage to capture even a
tiny amount of their vigor when it comes
to exposition teshiro mifune level gusto
is completely out of the question here
now there are some exceptions to this
the primary story quests give the
characters involved a bit more freedom
to move and naturally benefit from
hosting the more interesting plot
threats
that of jin's inescapable metamorphosis
from a by the book samurai square to
something a lot more unscrupulous for
the greater good
and how this change affects the
relationship with his loving but
uncompromising father figure the combat
encounters here also benefit from some
great set pieces
heightened by a strong musical score
that helps construct those
rousing blockbuster moments that always
seem to be able to pull at your emotions
no matter how impartial you're trying to
be
character specific tales have a little
more to offer too and see jin assist his
closest allies with their own
dire issues these multi-part questlines
can feel like wild goose chases
especially at the beginning of the game
but they all offer their own interesting
and violent stories of familial bonds
one of the game's major running themes
mythic tales are ghosts of tsushima's
most interesting quest offering though
they are few in number
these are explorations into the slightly
more supernatural elements of the world
featuring their own special animated
introductions they attempt to pull away
from the direct
point-to-point structure of the other
quests by asking you to do things like
look at a hand-drawn map and use your
own deductive exploration to find the
objective location
or they might offer simple mechanical
twists they can still feel like wild
goose chases but the rewards for the
more involved
nature of them are significant aside
from the main questline this is your
other avenue for earning new types of
weapons armor and abilities
usually after a climactic one-on-one
boss duel those jewels
and ghosts of tsushima's combat in
general is where the game does
successfully evoke samurai's cinema
jin's katana remains your primary weapon
throughout the whole game
it can fell enemies in a few quick
slices but likewise
jin can also die quickly after a few
good hits from opposing blades
this means blocking parrying and dodging
are the main
skills you need to learn how to both use
and overcome
properly and though there's a lot more
leeway here than something like sakura
shadows die twice
battles can still be over in seconds if
you make blunders
this gives every fight in the game a
degree of heart heart-pounding tension
from the game's first fight to its final
whether it be a lowly bandit or a master
swordsman
even in the otherwise wrote quests and
no matter what difficulty you're playing
on
combat does a fantastic job at
approximating the highly stylized
version of one versus many sword
fighting
as you might have seen in films like
harakiri or the samurai trilogy where
long standoffs and quick flourished
movements mark the ebb and flow of
suspense and excitement
most encounters can be initiated by
triggering a one-on-one standoff a tense
game of chicken where you need to wait
until your enemy has committed to an
attack
and then counter it in the split second
afterwards once that formality is passed
enemies will often try to surround you
and attack in tandem and decisive
success
often depends on patiently waiting for a
clear opening for attack otherwise you
might get interrupted by a follow-up
blow
perhaps you might need to wait for an
attack so you can perfectly deflect it
and counter or maybe you want to break
someone's guard to stagger them with
some decisive heavy strikes
indiscriminate flailing will see you
thrown off balance quickly
a resolve meter which you charge by
defeating enemies earns you
opportunities to perform devastating
special attacks
or heal yourself creating small risk
reward decisions to think about
frequently changing your active fighting
stance to better handle the different
kinds of weapons your opponents are
wielding
adds to the many considerations you need
to make as you do ranged opponents and
the extra tools you'll eventually have
at your disposal as jinn begins to learn
more deceitful methods of combat unlike
the game's quest cut scenes
jin's suite of animations along with the
gore and the foley associated with
combat
do a lot to make the act of sinking a
katana into flesh feel meaningful
little flourishes like how jin returns
to stance after a kill and the graceful
movements that accompany a successful
parry give everything an observable flow
switching stances which slows down time
just before dodging a hit and responding
with an advantageous technique feels
really good
in addition to exploring the world
combat is where ghosts of tsushima's
most transcendent moments lie
but it's not without its flaws
combat is sometimes let down by a couple
of major factors
when fighting on uneven terrain like
staggered rock formations and
inclines the tightly interlocked cause
and effect of parries and blows starts
to unravel
resulting in holes where animations
occur but their effects are not passed
on
the camera can also be an issue it
should be noted that ghost of tsushima
does not feature an enemy lock-on
function as part of its tool suite
presumably this is because enemies are
constantly attacking you from all
directions and you should always
have the ability to react quickly but
continually having to worry about the
camera in order to keep an eye on every
enemy within attack range
while also thinking about parrying
executing attack strings switching
stances
dodging ranged projectiles and keeping
your health up so you don't die on the
next hit can sometimes be a little much
when you're fighting in an open grassy
field and the camera actually pulls back
a bit to frame the dozens of enemies
closing in on you
ghost of sushima's sword fighting is
absolutely sublime but conditions aren't
always perfect
the biggest camera issues regularly
arise when fighting in tight spaces
indoors or in cluttered areas like enemy
encampments
of which there are many where tents
fences crates and other such
environmental objects exist
too often will you find yourself in a
situation where a solid object will be
blocking your vision of gin
your enemies or more importantly your
enemies weapons
all of the enemy attacks have a visible
tell and in the case of stronger
unblockable attacks they have
distinctive red glints moments before
they occur but much like agami ita's sui
wave slicer in the lone wolf and cub
series which begins with ito lowering
his sword beneath water
please bear with me here if you can't
see what your enemy is doing with their
weapon
there is very little you can do to
prevent your imminent death
and that can be incredibly frustrating
to be fair though you will
also kill people without them ever
seeing what you're doing when mongol
invaders turn up on the coast of
tsushima
jin and his honor stricken samurai
cohort find that their new enemies don't
play by their overly formal rules of
warfare
jin very quickly learns to accept that
he'll need to adopt more deceitful and
vicious tactics to combat the
overwhelming occupation of the island
meaning he'll have to get used to hiding
in the shadows
stabbing people in the back and using a
variety of tools to give himself an
unfair advantage the kind of warfare
tactics that were reportedly unheard of
in 13th century japan
a viable option in most scenarios
stealth is a relatively uncomplicated
affair in ghosts of tsushima
enemies are often placed in convenient
locations and are hard of hearing in
fact nearby neutral npcs will
hilariously act dramatically to your
actions while enemies stand motionless
in the beginning of the game it also
feels basic to a fault
i remember lamenting the fact that there
was no way to hide bodies
even though guards are alerted upon
discovering them but as you quickly earn
new ghost tools to use and upgrade your
tanto blade for quicker takedowns
it becomes clearer that this isn't a
stealth game focused on barely slipping
by unnoticed
though there are a number of annoying
instant fail stealth and tailing quests
but instead it's the kind of stealth
where you want to see how quickly and
viciously you can take down everyone in
the vicinity
that ended up justifying the inability
to hide bodies on top of explaining why
jin's footsteps are silent to begin with
and how he already managed to be a
fearless climbing master
even after i had completed the game's
main quest i gained a lot of enjoyment
from using the remaining enemy
encampments as playgrounds to terrorize
soldiers
i'd get creative with distraction tools
use more environmental kills turn
enemies against one another with
hallucinogenic darts
and hone my super long range grenade
throwing arm from the safety of a dark
rooftop i climbed onto with a grappling
hook
ghost of sushima's story hits hard in
the game's third and final act and it
ends in spectacular fashion
it left me with the same kinds of strong
emotions i felt at the end of all my
favorite samurai film epics and had me
eager to watch them all again
the game hits a lot of fantastic
cinematic highs and those
ultimately lifted above the trappings of
its familiar open-world quest design and
all the innate weaknesses that come with
it but those imperfections and dull
edges are definitely still there
ghost of tsushima is at its best when
you're riding your horse and taking in
the beautiful world on your own terms
armed with a sword and a screenshot
button allowing the environmental cues
and your own curiosity to guide you
it's not quite a criterion classic but a
lot of the time it sure looks like one
[Music]
i've never seen a samurai fight like
that
it was nothing